attacks from Russian forces.
Fred alright David Mckenzie,
thanks so much for that update.
The Wall Street journal's editor
in chief, is vowing to do
everything in their power to
secure the release of Evan
ceviche, the journalist who is
being held in Russia on spy
charges. This has president
Biden demands Herskovits release
. Upper right now, as they're
detaining the Russia they're
detaining the Wall Street
journal reporter go. The journal
says the white house needs to
expel the Russian ambassador and
Russian journalists from the us
something the president says he
has no immediate plans to do.
But leaders of more than 30 news
organizations around the world
signed a letter to Russia
demanding his release. The
Kremlin says accredited foreign
journalists can work safely in
Russia. Let's bring in bill
Browder. He is the CEO of
hermitage capital management,
and he's also the author of two
books, a red notice and, more
recently freezing order based on
his experiences in Russia and
becoming a target of Vladimir
Putin himself. Alright so good
to see you again, so can can you
help people understand why this
time this American journalist is
targeted? But it's pretty
straightforward that this is
hostage taking plain and simple.
Putin wants to have a high value
American hostage by taking a
Wall Street journal reporter
accomplishes that. Why does he
want hostage because he wants to
use that hostage use Evan as a
trading chip. Um for other
Russian people who have been
arrested, there's been a number
of Russian spies and other um,
money launderers and others who
have been arrested in the in by
the United States and around the
world, and Putin wants to
restock his supply of hostages
if you remember the there was a
previous hostage swap of the
basketball player, and now that
that she's home? Yeah Brittney
Griner now now they need another
one. And so that's what this is
all about. It also serves a
second purpose, which is very
important, which is that this is
a red line it even the soviets
during like Stalin didn't cross
it. You don't arrest western
journalists and by doing so, um
, if you're the editor of any
other newspaper, and you have
somebody on the ground in
Russia, you're probably going to
ask them to leave right now. And
so Putin doesn't like accurate
reporting of what's going on in
his country, and there's no
better way to get rid of all the
journalists, then to terrorize
one and let everyone else
scramble across the border. And
you mentioned Brittany grinder.
No wonder, um, since she was the
most recent taken and then
released. Do you see that? Gersh
Cavett's journey? His experience
is going to be very similar, or
do you see that Russia will
treat him his case differently?
Um that negotiations or even
demands would be played out
differently. Well I think he's a
higher value hostage. I mean,
she you know, he's a journalist
. Um you know, it's it doesn't
require a campaign for anyone to
understand that how important he
is, he is. He is somebody who,
um, you know, works for the wall
Street journal immediately, the
president says, let him out. And
so I would imagine that. That
that from the Russians
perspective this is this is
somebody really important that
they can do a lot with, but the
one thing I would say is that
I've seen these things play out
and they take a long time and we
shouldn't expect anything to
happen very quickly. The
Russians will want to convict
him in their accord for
espionage. They want to give him
a very long sentence you want.
They want us all to squirm and
feel terrible about it. And at
the point of maximum pain for
the west. Then they'll offer
some type of hostage exchange.
But that's not gonna happen very
quickly. And in my prediction,
um in the last year, many news
organizations, American news
organizations pulled a lot of
their journalists out of Moscow
out of Russia. Anticipating that
you know there would be a real
crackdown because there were
threats against journalists who
are going to say anything to
report anything that was um,
yeah, antithetical to what
Vladimir Putin would want
publicized and now recently,
white house spokesperson John
Kirby said yesterday that
Americans need to get out of
Russia because, as we see now
there have been many who have
returned or many who have stayed
. Uh, what are your thoughts
about western journalists as a
whole who are inside Russia? And
particularly now that get device
has been detained. What do you
advise them to do? Well sadly, I
would advise them to leave the
country there's really not much
that that one can do if Putin
decides to take more hostages,
all it does is it just
exacerbates the problem as much
as we'd like to have accurate
reporting for every single
person out there? They're human
beings with their you know,
wanting freedom and having
families and so on and so forth,
and I don't think that anyone
should be put in harm's way, and
it's clear. Putin is not playing
by any set of rules. They're
just all rule books have been
torn up. You don't arrest
western journalists. Even Stalin